welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars Ahsoka episode 2 toil in trouble a
reference to the witches of
Shakespeare's Macbeth Act 4 scene one
because in Ahsoka which is be crazy
there is Val and foul is fair in the
state of the new Republic so let's break
down this episode soon by saying and
explain why Morgan L Smith said time
before the word space where we're going
we don't need Pergo and yes you may have
noticed I'm wearing our fulcrum shirt
available at nerd riot.shop it's the
best way to support we're doing here at
new rockstars also please subscribe to
all three channels to the new rockstars
Network especially the break room where
you can find our Ahsoka after show
Wikileaks my Easter egg breakdown of
episode 1 is already on this main new
rockstars channel in a separate video
okay the lucasfilm intro to episode 2
has changed since episode one that
episode the helmets and Droid heads were
reflected only in red light but here it
is back to a mix of red and blue red on
Vader blue on 3PO blue on a clone
trooper helmet a Rex Cameo this season
read on the HK assassin Droid Blue On
The Inquisitor moroque blue on huyang
red on the Stormtrooper blue on Chopper
and then red onto beans helmet the
episode so it opens with Ahsoka in
sabine's hospital room on lothal from
White we hear bits of dialogue echoing
from last episode
[Music]
the voices end when Ahsoka wakes Sabine
up with this sound effect
Sabine after sabine's defeat last
episode and huyang's absolute burying of
her ego this episode Sabine faces some
major doubts in her abilities as a Jedi
and her Force sensitivity but her vivid
dreams and the sound with which Ahsoka
pulled her out of these dreams makes it
seem like Sabine still has some unwieldy
connection to some kind of mysticism the
Sith rule of two favors parians of
course reflected with the master and
Apprentice of episode 1's title but
episode 2 invokes witches bubble bubble
toil and trouble via bird and cauldron
bubble and witches come in how many
Hocus Pocus fans three so who are the
three witches of Ahsoka perhaps Sabine
struggle with the force despite these
Mystic qualities could actually give her
a different status a night sister so our
three witches of Ahsoka could be Morgan
elsmith shinhati and Sabine Wren shin
and Balin are no longer Jedi but they
are something else and these opposing
Natural Forces could explain why Ahsoka
and Sabine struggle to work together
it's not enough that Sabine is
Mandalorian she bristled with her house
Visa lineage something else is calling
to Sabine and she could be revealed as
part of the night's sister ancestry I'm
just starting off with the reach Theory
this episode to alienate the half of you
who watch these videos for like Aura
best translations like I'm a YouTube
huyang Sabine reports there were two
galaxies and then
a pathway appeared between them
where did the path in our galaxy begin
yeah Ahsoka leans forward clearly having
theorized on this path and this second
galaxy in the past the starter planet we
learn is ctOS where Balin and shin
approached the stonehenge-esque ruin
with their Ada Class Shuttle now
Stonehenge in our world was constructed
sometime between 3000 BC and 2000 BC and
its original function remains Up For
Debate by historians and archaeologists
perhaps a burial site perhaps something
associated with astronomy but the design
of these ruins at Ahsoka clearly Builds
on that historical mystery as this sea
top structure is clearly part of a star
map but when it compared to the Arcana
Knight sister ruins we saw last episode
those were far more preserved the state
of these ruins indicate something even
older something more forgotten you may
remember the Jedi Ruins on the planet
tython from the Mandalorian episode the
tragedy but I've always wondered if
those Jedi Ruins could have been built
on top of something even older because
even the music Kevin Kinder composes for
these shots makes us feel like we are
peering in On A Lost Civilization
[Music]
thank you it's clear they're trying to
evoke something from a completely
foreign Galaxy we're not in tattooing
anymore and thank God because I've hated
sand it's quartz forever irritating it's
everywhere anyway balen says tatter I
believe we have located The Reflex point
on sitos now if Morgan and ellsbeth was
able to tell Ahsoka that the map sphere
was on Arcana how did she not know where
the reflex point was was Morgan just
unable to decode the map this tells us
something must be significant about
Sabine and her insights she was one who
connected the three faces and it really
could just be because of a night sister
connection with Morgan and shin the
power of three has finally synced Baylin
looks up at the sky through the concave
Arc of one of these columns
all right
yeah that horn makes it sound like
something is calling to him perhaps
another whale call of the Pergo since it
is their path that he's gazing out at
Ahsoka foresenses Sabine and Shin's duel
from the night before
so this is called psychometry and it's a
relatively new Force ability that was
introduced in Clone Wars episode hunt
for zero used by the Jedi Quinlan Voss
no relation but I wish and the Obi-Wan
Kenobi series revealed that Quinlan boss
Survived The Purge and traveled on the
path of runaway Jedi so who knows maybe
Ahsoka and Quinlan cross paths at some
point sabine's low cat regards Ahsoka
curiously as if appreciating those
cat-like points on top of ahsoka's laku
and that lorian HK Droid appears way
earlier than I initially spotted it he's
in the shot right after Ahsoka lights up
the Ezra hologram as that loath cat did
to warn Sabine it now hisses at the
Droid here and Ahsoka takes it down
Sabine dismantles his HK Droid head and
I just really appreciate how heavy it
seems when she rotates it on the table
the weight of it tells us how much it
must have hurt fighting these things
hand-to-hand also little details
sabine's fingernail polish is chipped
from her picking at them and probably
from all the gear tinkering she does
Sabine does work on an explosive Droid
head in a hospital and deduces it is
from corellia remember Sabine is a
former Imperial Weapon Specialist She's
Not Afraid of doing this kind of work
Morgan L Smith catches up with the rest
on cetas and Balin asks this place was
not built by the Jedi
whose book is it
and ancient people from a distant Galaxy
ooh just by looking at these ruins even
before the star map lights up Morgan
knows what they are which tells us that
they are not night sister ruins if they
were she probably would have claimed
them as the work of her ancestors as she
did with the ruins on Arcana Morgan uses
a green frame to boil The Cauldron I
mean to activate the sphere green was
the color of the sorcery used by the
night sisters in Clone Wars Morgan
explains this
is our galaxy and then the star map
appears around them it looks so great
and she lines up another galaxy in a
ring and this ring notice is lined with
Pergo the hyperspace whales this tells
us that this must be a kind of migratory
path for the Pergo it's something that
they are all destined to head back to
and this is where they wish thrawn and
Ezra in the rebels finale Morgan goes on
in my favorite line of the episode that
is our destination Pathway to peridia
some call it that the children of the
Jedi Temple call it that it comes from
old stories Fairy Tales tales which are
based on truths so much to dig into here
the pathway to paridia is the new thing
in Star Wars lore it sounds like it's a
fairy tale that Baylen knew about from
his days in the Jedi Temple but Morgan
is saying the legend was based on truth
and I love that she said this because it
recalls an interesting line from Ahsoka
in The crucial Rebels episode season 2
episode 21 Twilight of The Apprentice
part one there's always a bit of Truth
in Legends truth in legends in that
moment Ahsoka was affirming things like
the legend of mortis with the father son
and daughter real experiences she went
through as well as the legends of the
Sith and the Jedi but it was also a meta
line from Dave filoni that the Star Wars
expanded universe stories AKA Legends
still bore truth this line came months
after the force awakens came out after
Disney's acquisition of Star Wars and
they re-categorized so many stories as
Legends but at this point forward for
Dave filoni that was really his mission
with every Star Wars title starting the
next season of rebels season 3 with the
character of thrawn who you could say is
really the best of expanded universe
fiction from Timothy zahn's novel
starting in 1991 at this point had been
categorized as Legends but with the
return of thrawn he made thrawn Kanan
once more now when we ask who built this
star map who built these ruins there are
a number of ancient civilizations in
Star Wars lore we could look at that
predate the Sith and the Jedi like the
grisk was a warring species from the
unknown regions that threatened thrawn
civilization the chis ascendancy but I
am betting that the ancient people from
a distant Galaxy that Morgan refers to
are the rakutans so the word Kata aka
the builders were an ancient amphibious
humanoid species the race believed to
have invented hyperspace technology as a
force sensitive race the dark side
corrupted the rakutans and turned them
into cruel Warriors who enslaved every
other species they came across forming
their infinite Empire the reconnaissance
actually came up in the Knights of the
Old Republic game which also involved
star Maps such as this Dave filoni and
his team are clearly into Knights of the
Old Republic they keep bringing up
references to Knights of the Old
Republic details like the crate dragon
and its giant Pearl from the Mandalorian
season 2 premiere we also know that
lucasfilm wants us to remember the
rakatans because they include it in
Andor Andor of all titles this cryptic
little Easter egg it's a quarter
skystone the ancient world celebrate is
the uprising against the rakatan
Invaders the uprising against the
recontinent Invaders the moment the
current ancient era of Star Wars
civilization overthrew the rakatan
Empire so with this detail in Andor
there were contents shifted from being
an apocryphal Legends backstory to firm
Star Wars Canon so my theory is that the
ricottens are the ones who built these
ruins the Knight sisters are a cult from
that rakatan era using dark sorcery
predating the Jedi in the Sith and the
Pergo are the species of whales that the
ricottens derived hyperspace technology
from we might be looking at a pathway
not just through space but through time
because Morgan says here the wrong calls
to me
across time
and space normally astrophysicists say
space before time space time according
to Einstein's theory of relativity which
I recognize does not apply to the Star
Wars physics but in our world according
to theory of relativity gravity affects
our perception of the passage of time
and time is a dimension theoretically
navigable the way space is this has been
the basis of much Science Fiction and
Fantasy including Frank Herbert's Dune
Christopher Nolan's Interstellar and yes
George Lucas is Star Wars and Morgan
says time first though and I believe the
reason this path to paridia leads to one
fixed point when thrawn as a living
figure would presumably be able to move
around in that Galaxy wherever he is the
reason why it just points to one spot is
that this path doesn't lead to a point
in space it leads to a point in time and
this wouldn't be the first time Star
Wars touched on time travel because in
Rebels season 4 episode 13 Ezra Ventures
into the lothal Jedi Temple and follows
projections of the loath wolves 3 portal
to a realm called the world Between
Worlds it's a mystical Dimension that
connects the force to all of space and
time the imagery of these rotating lines
in the star maps in Ahsoka totally
Echoes what we saw in the world between
Between Worlds in this Dimension Ezra
hears Echoes of many past Star Wars
moments and he revisits the moment that
Ahsoka fought Darth Vader and malachor
back in the season 2 finale our man
Alters history just a little bit or you
could argue had already altered history
now filoni developed the world Between
Worlds he says in conversations with
George Lucas and he based it on the wood
between the worlds and C.S Lewis's
Chronicles of Narnia to be clear Dave
filoni did tell Cinema Bland in 2018
that they destroyed the temple at the
end of that episode because they didn't
want this to be like an ongoing Trope in
Star Wars here's what he said I don't
really think of it as time travel it's
not really a thing where you go through
one door and out another in a different
time the world Between Worlds is really
about knowledge and gaining knowledge as
the Doom wolf says what's in there is
knowledge and destruction you can gain
knowledge of the future or Futures that
may happen and you can see things that
happen in the past you can at times
choose to alter them but it is perilous
to do so and when you alter something
you don't know if that's not the way it
always happens so destruction is the
other half of what's in there when you
go through these doorways you're in
Peril of Destruction because you're
missing all sorts of things that would
have happened or things that would have
happened otherwise you know so it's a
dangerous game but it's not something we
are here going in and out of different
doors it's an extension of the Jedi's
ability to perceive the future and the
past as described in Empire Strikes Back
yeah okay polony but if Ezra saved
Ahsoka there's still pretty much time
travel it's just hard to look at this
show with its wolf Motif skull and hati
the Norse mythological wolves who chase
the Sun and Moon across the sky the
Knights of the Old Republic star Maps
the mentions of ancient civilizations
and thrawn speaking to Morgan through
time and not conclude that there might
be some connection to the world Between
Worlds and this is all too much for you
we are in the middle of a Rebels
re-watch series on the new rockstars
Channel be sure to check those out and
keep an eye out for our breakdown of
season three and season four that are
coming in the next week thank you to
betterhelp for sponsoring this video
watching stuff frame by frame is great
but it can also be really rewarding to
zoom out and look at things like story
pacing and character development for a
movie you can just let it play out but
when you're the target of analysis it's
better to get some help from betterhelp
regardless if you have a clinical mental
health issue like depression or anxiety
or if you're just going through a hard
time therapy can give you some tools to
approach your life in a very different
way with better help you can tap into a
network of over 30 000 licenses and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues it's easy to
sign up and get matched with a therapist
there's a link in my description it's
betterhelp.com new rockstars to get
started just answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what what your preferences
are better help will then match you with
the therapist from their Network that's
right for you if you don't really fit in
with that therapist which is a common
thing with therapy you can easily switch
to a therapist for free without
stressing about insurance or who's in
your network or anything like that you
can always benefit from talking to
somebody and getting things off your
chest so if you're struggling consider
online therapy with better help click
the link in the description or visit
betterhelp.com do rockstars clicking
that link helps support this channel but
it also gets you 10 off your first month
of better help one more detail I gotta
point out here as Morgan listens to
those Whispers through time it does
sound like the whisper says the word
Morgan
so is thrawn part of the night sisters
himself or is there another acolyte of
Thrones wherever he is whenever he is
who is calling out to Morgan as Morgan
leaves Baylin tells Shin that once they
find thrawn for Summit will be War for
others a new beginning but for them wow
such as you've never dreamed
balon's objective is beyond the rebel vs
Empire conflict of the present
generation beyond the Sith or the Jedi
whose teachings that they practice now
really an ancient interpretation of the
force that has been lost to the ages
okay on to corellio which has an
atmospheric gate similar to the planet
of scarif in Rogue one the surface of
corellia is covered in water with
industrial interlocking docks and
Pathways we actually saw corellia from
the street level in the opening sequence
of solo a Star Wars story that's where
Han Solo got his start I like how in the
pods below you can actually see vast
Imperial Star Destroyers in various
states of deconstruction the back parts
of their triangular shape still visible
Ahsoka Parks the T6 beside the Phantom
2. this is the detachable shuttle that
connects to the ghost the primary ship
in Rebels Regional supervisor Min Weaver
is played by Peter Jacobson Long Time
character actor best known as Dr Chris
talbon house in D the ghost screws
Astromech droid Chopper sits in the
Droid Port of the Phantom 2 as was the
case in Rebels he is voiced here by Dave
filoni himself
as before whenever Chopper talks it's
clearly polony uttering something that's
been distorted and here it kind of
sounds like watch your step Ahsoka this
is the first time you we've seen Chopper
in live action other than when they
rolled around on stage at Star Wars
celebration in 2022 unlike other
astronauts we've seen his head Dome can
kind of wobble compared to r2d2s that
can only rotate laterally this gives
Chopper a bit more zaniness and Sass our
man's always talking so Weaver
explains to ahsokan Hera that most of
Morgan elsmith's pro-imperial staff
still work at this facility you will
still find X Imperials at every level of
the new republic government he goes on
on to say the average worker doesn't
care about the nuances of Galactic
politics they have loyalty so long as
they're paid and you I'm a businessman
General
my loyalty is to my investors son of a
like in season three of the
Mandalorian this is part of lucasfilm's
long game of showing the vulnerabilities
of the new Republic that are just gonna
make it easier for threats like the
first order to rise this will debate
over the new Republic's defense
priorities is better explored in Chuck
windig's aftermath novels as well as
Claudia Gray's bloodline which goes into
Leia organa's Fallout with a new
Republic in the formation of the
resistance huyang meanwhile continues to
practice some Jedi protocol as he plays
Matchmaker to try to get Sabine to
return to Ahsoka but I like how he does
not flatter her I have known
the centuries and I can safely say your
aptitude for the force would fall short
of them all I love this line because it
shows that Sabine isn't just like a
randomly apt user of the force she sucks
but again she still has some mysticism
with these dreams and they may be rooted
in something older than Jedi Orthodoxy
meanwhile Weaver explains that they
produce nine hyperspace engines from the
old Star Destroyers for some new ship
that Hera calls on because the
new Republic isn't working on anything
that big we learn later that this is for
Morgan ellswitz eye of Scion and nine
hyperdrive cores is totally excessive
you should only need one but for
something that's big you need nine and
in our numerological focus on the number
three Magic Number Nine is three sets of
three Weaver says general sindula isn't
authorized to see what projects these
drives might be used for and he reports
the only droids they have at this
facility include ccl's iw37s hv7s and
other load lifters which are all loading
Droids that we've seen in Star Wars
before but the protocol Droid totally
rats out her boss that she saw in HK
Droid and recently prevented her from
inspecting inventory 5 days prior in
these red suited Neo-Nazi say yeah I
guess now's a good time to make a move
literally all of these operators pull
blasters on them and this fourth one
Ahsoka uses the force to pull the
Blaster out of her hand with the hand
that is still holding the lightsaber
hilt she does this in the fight with
morocc later it's just an interesting
move that we saw Keller and Beck do on
the Mandalorian when he rescued grogu
Ahsoka is stopped outside by The
Inquisitor Muro with an HK Droid The
Inquisitor unfurls the cape like a
samurai duel now we still don't know who
morocc is but the physical performance
was done by Paul Darnell a stunt
performer a Jurassic world Matrix
resurrections and tenet Ahsoka stabs the
HK Droid and continues to drive toward
The Inquisitor using the Droid as a
shield four beat until both lightsaber
wielders chop into pieces at this point
The Inquisitor fires up the second half
of the lightsaber and starts looking
like a true Inquisitor and we're just
assuming this is an Inquisitor because
they're carrying the same kind of
lightsaber The Inquisitor does and yes
Moro does look like the eighth brother
with that helmet but the eighth brother
died at the end of season two so who
knows this whole section is just great
rebels action Hera evades Blaster fire
as Chopper snaps at her I can't just
shoot it down it would crash into the
port city just ready a tracking device
and don't miss this time good Lord it
sounds like when Harris says shooting
the demo crash into the Port City below
Chopper's response is and that's bad
those of us who call Chopper a war
criminal remember Rebels season 2
episode 9 stealth strike win Choppers
sabotage the gravity well in the
Imperial interdictor destroying it and
two other ships accounting for thousands
and thousands of deaths don't tell me it
was wartime don't compare it to Luke
destroying the Death Star this is
totally different there are other ways
Chopper could have handled this and you
just cannot ignore all the times he was
a little stinker I get it crawling
Chopper war criminal you would have to
call many of these characters war
criminals but none of them are as mean
and as stinky as Shopper is though In
fairness to Chopper here it seems like
everyone on that corellian base were
Imperial sympathizers so you know I
guess I can't really blame them Chopper
snaps at Hera
no I did not go through your stuff and
ass Chopper puts his hands on his hips
it sounds like he chirps did you go
through my stuff and then yes you're
dead Rook rotates a lightsaber blade and
chunks it at Ahsoka baylen's Ada Class
Shuttle fires on Ahsoka and morocc
Boards it and I think my favorite Ashoka
move of this episode she no look Dodges
the lightsaber as it boomerangs past her
shoulder the tracker that Chopper uses
looks somewhat like the puck that
Obi-Wan Kenobi uses to track Jango Fett
in Attack of the Clones but Hera rolls
the Phantom 2 over the CT transport
giving Chopper a window to toss this
track around the hole and it is freaking
badass kind of reminds me of when Rey
rotates the Millennium Falcon in the
force awakens with a dead drop to a lion
Finn in the Gunner seat
[Music]
look I know some of you want to pretend
the sequel Trilogy didn't happen but
come on this was sick Chopper does a
fist bump and then flexes Droid arms
he's a war criminal back on lothal
Sabine gives her locat a well-earned
scratchy scratch for saving her and
ahsoka's life and Sabine digs out her
old Mandalorian armor that she wore
throughout Rebels one pauldron with the
rebel Crest one paltry decorated with a
Pergo some chess pieces and then two
wrist van braces that were given to her
by the Mandalorian protector Ben Rao in
season three Trials of the darksaber now
this painting of the armor is actually
what we salsa being wearing right at the
end of the rebels series the paint job
in the armor was different throughout
most of the show we see Sabine kneeling
in front of her helmet and using a knife
to cut her hair Kane and Jairus does the
same thing in Rebels season 4 episode 10
Jedi Knight shaving his beard and
cutting his knot with the Knight doesn't
mean Sabine could be headed to death
maybe maybe not because Sabine would
always keep her hair short before
because her head her scalp would get hot
underneath that Mandalorian helmet and
now she's back in the armor Hera and
Ahsoka watch Weaver arrested by the new
Republic officers was shifts marked with
police and orbash and Ahsoka says it's
not loyalty
it's great we cease to be in back in her
armor on the lothal tower at sundown the
light didn't match in the final epilogue
scene of rebels perfectly she touches
the mural she painted of the ghost crew
just as she did in that scene and
Natasha Leo bordizzo is shot from Ezra's
perspective at this downward angle
making her head look just a bit larger
than it would normally if she's never
looked more like her animated self also
liking the final scene of rebels Ahsoka
appears behind her ready to whisker away
on a mission to find and rescue Ezra but
there's one key difference in that scene
Ahsoka returned with staff in white
robes now ahsoka's robes are a darker
gray Dave filoni has long been
interested in the character of Gandalf
like when talking about Kanan as an
incomplete Mentor felony said a lot of
my modeling comes from a lot of my
exposure to reading Tolkien Gandalf is
not a complete Mentor he's way more down
the path than anyone else but he's not
complete that's why he's very
symbolically gray he has to figure it
out along the way and then attain a new
level after people thought Ahsoka had
died when her voice appeared in the rise
of Skywalker filoni tweeted an image
likening her with Gandalf and the rebels
finale Ahsoka was in white the the sun
behind her meant to evoke Gandalf's
return as Gandalf the White but now
Ahsoka in Gray suggests a reverse of
that transformation she's less of the
enlightened perfect mentor and now she's
more of an uncertain gray Jedi but that
uncertainty is where she needs to be for
the road ahead Ahsoka allows Sabine to
take them out to hyperspace calling her
Padawan and I don't think we're looking
at a Jedi master and Apprentice but
something in between so this episode
ends with the eye of Scion and orbit
over sea toss in the denab system its
ninth hyperdrive core plugs into this
vast ring assuming the two big engines
on either side contain two cores each
that would add up to nine but at the top
of this is the golden ship that we saw
Morgan leaving cetos in earlier morocc
Balin and shin appear through a
different medium of hologram one based
more on green dust this is different
than the blue flickering Holograms we
normally see and it's a lot clearer
better resolution I'm assuming this is a
Kind of Night sister Magic based on the
green color tone but it shows us that
this ancient magic is far superior to
the current technology Balin meditates
for a moment and he says ahsoka's
presence in the force is elusive but her
determination is vivid he goes on to say
kill her
it'll be a shame
there's so few Jedi left sentimental
truth
a curious exchange of these three shin
marak and balen Balin is the only one of
these three to have not yet gone saber
to saber with Ahsoka we know from
Trailer footage he will but he is
reluctant to do so as a former Jedi he
doesn't like the idea of purging any
other Jedi bear in mind that somewhere
out there though is Luke Skywalker and
truly with the Last Jedi the Jedi Order
will come to an end and huyang will cry
please support us with this fulcrum
shirt available at nerdright.shop you
can subscribe to all three of the
channels in the new rockstars Network
new rockstars the break room and the
Deep dive huge thanks to Noah Chan for
his help with this breakdown you can
follow me on all social platforms that
eat a boss thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time bye
[Music]